tout
oh lalala lalala
quel angle en france est première de
couche toi mon pote
bienvenue sur des visites en direct tous
les soirs on sera là à 18h15 pétantes
on va vous faire revivre tout ce qui
s'est passé dans la journée ils sont
tous là où qu'ils sont beaux grosse
émotion ce soir parce que ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'on attend de moi
ça fait quatre mois je suis chez moi je
dis ça va démarrer quand cette émission
non mais c'est bon quoi j'ai tout fait
je faisais des osso buco à la maison et
darchy pas remonter pour ma femme sur la
tête d'une équerre qu'est-ce qu'on est
content d'être là pour gad elmaleh ou
gad elmaleh
[Applaudissements]
gad elmaleh ou gad elmaleh galles
et
m
est ce que notre ami m'a dit je te
rappelle que je m'appelle thierry
beccaro
e
hanouna
pas mal non
[Applaudissements]
bon j'imagine juste devant le début dans
la presse alors ils ont chanté avec des
noms de famille
galli n'a pas trouvé tout de suite je
vous explique vous pouvez réagir pendant
cette émission puisque les soldes en
direct sur twitter http sur facebook à
ma soeur sur le boubou que vous pouvez
dire des choses à nous dire ce que vous
pensez de l'émission réagir sur ce que
ce dont on va parler c est bien celle
oiseaux trotter qui sera avec nous tous
les jours
[Applaudissements]
merci je vous dire avant la fin de cette
émission je vous ferai découvrir qui se
cache derrière l'oiseau tonnerre
[Musique]